[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
country superstars keith urban and
mickey guyton kicked off the 56th
academy of country music awards by
recognizing just how far we've come
nashville is back the two hosts made it
clear in their opening monologue
that the night was all about celebrating
progress
we've been through so much but i'm very
very proud to say that we are
very much on our way back and we've done
it with a lot of fight
and a lot of help speaking of help right
after that intro
mickey acknowledged the audience which
was full of health care workers from
vanderbilt health
you guys are our army right now and this
would not be possible without you so
thank you all so so much hey man mickey
very good
recognizing progress was a running theme
throughout the night of hardin hits live
from nashville
and mickey officially made history as
the first black woman to host the show
it's been a year of first for you yes
you had uh let's see you had grammy
nominations
you got to play on the grammys for the
first time first time hosting acms
and you all say it's one other thing i'm
missing let's see
oh you had a baby for the first time
i had a baby i love him so much mickey
performed with keith at last year's
ceremony
while she was pregnant with her now
three-month-old son grayson
their 2020 duet went on to get the
attention of the show's organizers
which led to mickey's history-making
moment this year
well it's so crazy because grayson was
with me when i performed with keith
and you know he was still in my belly
and now he's here and now i'm hosting
with keith so it's such a
a full circle moment you know i just
can't even comprehend how beautiful
this moment is as predicted keith and
mickey's chemistry was just
right i knew right away that we could do
we could do this
effortlessly together so uh if we could
do that song having had really no
rehearsal and feel very very good about
playing
together just sort of off the cuff to
some degree
we'll be fine on the show luke bryan who
won entertainer of the year
even gave the hosting duo a shout out
during his acceptance speech
congrats mickey and keith what a great
night you guys have done
the two took the stage with stellar solo
performances
mickey sang a song she originally wrote
as a prayer
hold on
and she introduced keith keith freaking
urban
who rocked out to an upbeat rendition of
tumbleweed
before their big night at the acms
mickey opened up to et about her
thoughts on hosting and performing
on one of country music's biggest stages
you know it's so crazy because i've been
pursuing country music for 10 years
and for so long i was just trying to fit
in
and the moment i just let go of all of
those limitations that i set upon myself
and kind of sort of from the industry
everything turned around
and now i'm here in this moment and i
just want to break down those doors and
open them for everybody that wants to
come through because country music is
such a beautiful genre and there's a
reason why
two outsiders like keith irvin and
myself fell in love with it because the
music is truly beautiful
and and i just feel honored
you